they call it the cage the jail but this
squalid room is no ordinary prison this
is Europe and some of those inside are
Asylum Seekers who claim they were held
by Bulgarian border forces
in a joint investigation we filmed this
place five times in six weeks
every time we saw people inside
here you see them Led Out by a Bulgarian
officer
we showed the video to refugees near the
border this man claims he was held there
for three days with little food or water
others say they were beaten and detained
for hours before being pushed back to
Turkey
foreign
used by Bulgarian Border Police on
occasion a car of the eu's Border
Protection Agency frontex can be seen
outside
they say they're investigating the
information we shared with them
the makeshift prison backs onto the
street we ask the Bulgarian government
about the refugees claims and why people
were held there they didn't respond
we talked to Border Police today to ask
them if they kept migrants on site they
told us they didn't and that they're all
sent to processing centers
of abuse are common
the refugees shared this unverified
video of what they say are Bulgarian
officials beating people
illegal pushbacks and abuse have been
reported at several EU borders in
Hungary people spoke of beating by the
authorities
and they were police but they hit me two
of them with their legs and they put me
down on the ground
some refugees have also reported being
tied up outside for hours or held in
containers people were kept inside such
containers up to 12 hours often kept up
to 60 people in such a contained space
when showing resistance being
sprayed with pepper spray or one one
person reported also the use of tear gas
from the small Windows of the sides of
of the containers Hungary utterly
rejects the allegations saying officers
act legally and humanely
Bulgaria says it follows International
and domestic laws but people seeking
protection are reporting abuse and
detention in clandestine prisons alleged
black sites in Europe Siobhan Robbins
Sky News Bulgaria